so uh jumping on in
um if someone has actually never seen
anything that you guys have done before
what is the first thing you want them
watching and why I really do that's a
really good question wow I mean I think
you know
will and I are sort of strange beasts
were were very cynical and comedy tends
to be uh run hard in life and also in
the movies we've made and yet we're also
sort of
um have a tremendous amount of heart and
so we're always looking for kind of that
combination I think in our work and I
think it's sort of is defined a lot of
our uh our early stuff and I think uh
with this movie specifically it's been
interesting because we've now been sort
of over indexing a little bit in the
heart Department I think which was a
nice process on this one but I think if
we had to pick one distinctive piece of
work
I think it's a strange one which is
there's a a PSA that we developed
um for uh Oregon donate
um which we kind of wrote about a
character that was not redeemable until
after his death when he realized that he
was an organ donate it was called the
world's biggest household and he um and
it I think I think it possessed both of
those two qualities yeah and it's a
small piece and it's an odd one to
choose because it doesn't really stand
up in terms of length time or scope to
any of the movies we've done but it
definitely speaks directly to our
sensibility which is what Josh said
which is kind of the darkness and a
little bit of the cynicism and the humor
with a Twist of kind of heart at the end
because ultimately we're kind of softies
so listen obviously people want to make
movies with you you had you know been
able to make a career in Hollywood which
is uh like winning a lottery but if you
could get the financing to make anything
you want uh what would you make and why
well this is not just timely Lyle was a
big passion project of ours it's a book
that we've always loved together
collectively and the rights were
definitely difficult to to get and um we
found a great fracture point where they
had lapsed and we were able to come in
so that was this was an actual dream
come true because we'd also wanted to
make a musical forever so
um there's definitely you know lots of
mountains in front of us to climb but um
this specifically was something that
checked a lot of boxes for us because it
was beloved for both of us as a book and
um I think you know again the musical
component was something really exciting
to have done but I think
what else I mean I think what what we've
been trying to do
um which we've been lucky to do is just
expand out of our comfort zone and we
just did a sci-fi film that's coming out
after this with Anthony Ramos for
Universal called distance so we're
starting to kind of get to those
projects I think that you're describing
jumping into with with Lyle obviously
you need uh the lead voice and I'm just
curious had you been thinking about Sean
how did it actually land on you know
Sean doing the voice and did anyone else
come close to actually Landing the role
um you know our decision to make the
character not speak which was you know a
big part of the book was a hard one
because we were really worried
defensively that the studio was going to
ask us to do that because it's sort of
logical in these kind of movies to you
know boost the main character with a
comedic Superstar behind it
um so once we got past that hurdle it
was well how do we we voice him and I
think what we were looking for was
something that really someone that
really resembled the character and had
kind of an innocence and an openness so
we thought about well is there a teenage
singer that you know that should do this
role and I think you know we wanted it
to be somebody on the young side for
sure and we also wanted it to be kind of
a voice that really stopped you in your
tracks
um and that's actually a very short list
when you come down to it um and so there
were a lot of those people I mean there
were five names on that list I'm sure
you can imagine who they were um you
know and we actually looked at the list
visually we put it up on the wall and we
thought about them we were like you know
what's great about Sean is
he's an innocent and there's not a lot
that you know about him in a way do you
know I mean you you know here and there
are some facts but there's there there's
still a blank slate there
um and I think for us that's what Drew
him to us really as a first choice
because we felt like we want it not to
feel like it comes with a tremendous
amount of baggage in that choice and I
think once we started to talk to him you
know he spoke of his
stage fright his anxiety his you know
stepping into the power of his talent
and what what that struggle was about
for him and that felt very much
thematically you know where Lyle was as
a character and so for us it just it all
sort of made a logical sense and and
fell into place and he really surprised
us in a way because we asked him to do a
different style of music than he was
used to you know Justin and benj are you
know they have musical roots and there's
a lot of interpretation in that kind of
text versus what you might do in a pop
song which is sometimes a little bit
more about a vocal line with less
interpretation and a lot of the
interpretation comes in the production
of a track and Sean was actually able to
really do that in a raw and really
unexpected way so I think for us it felt
like just a great marriage of you know a
person bringing their own sensibility to
something and kind of what we had hoped
the character could emulate so it was a
good was a good match yeah I was just
surprised Chris Pratt didn't get the
voice role because you know
I'm obviously joking um you uh listen
making this movie no matter how much
money you had there's always going to be
an obstacle with time budget there's
always obstacles
um so what ended up being the biggest
hurdles that you were nervous about uh
while making the film
well you know it's I think the biggest
hurdles are you know that musicals
require a completely different way of
making than any other movie you know I
mean it's a it's a bit of an art form
that's gone out of Hollywood you know it
takes a friend of ours who made a bunch
of musical told us that you know you
really have to make the movie well in
advance of making the movie and most
movies are not set up in that way now
you know what I mean there's release you
know targets that you're hitting and the
you know we were very lucky Sony was
very eager to get this made and into the
theaters and so a lot of our hurdles had
to do with time in terms of time to
rehearse time to get the songs early
enough to really build these big
sequences we were able to do it but it
required a lot of sort of overlapping
you know we were shooting while we would
then go all night and rehearse and then
come back to the stages so it was you
know it was uh it was a journey of time
which a lot of movies are but this one
particularly was was very hard in that
department
uh obviously Javier is very selective
with the roles he takes uh you've spoken
about uh the studio didn't think you
could get him and you you were able to
get him I'm just curious what do you end
up drinking the night that he says yes
because it's such a great casting scoop
do you know what I mean like how I'm
making a joke about this but you know I
can't imagine your reaction when he
actually said yes we had such a strange
way in which we found out which is that
we had talked to him you know over
several almost four long six six five
six six long and you know ultimately he
you know he told us I need the weekend
to decide if I'm absolutely going to do
this or not but you know he he was
nervous about am I funny enough can I do
the singing you know get a lot of
personal he's very hard on himself as an
actor and he really wanted to make sure
he could deliver and he was on vacation
with his family and he um he went off to
the beach and coming out of the water
was a small child holding a crocodile
inflatable raft and I think he thought
well this okay this says I have to do
this movie he grabbed the kid's wrath
and took a picture of it and sent it to
us so we thought we weren't going to
hear until Monday and then on a fro on a
Sunday we got this picture of him
standing on a beach holding the rav we
were like what does this mean like is
this yes or no and so we sort of assumed
him that yes and went out and got drunk
I think I had to kill him but I totally
believe everything I saw in the movie
about a crocodile being able to sing I
believed everything the only thing that
I really was like I don't think this is
true is seeing everyone drive around New
York City without traffic like that was
my one thing in the sand where I'm like
this is too far I'm making a joke
obviously but
um you know no you're you're not wrong
but you know inversely closing Fifth
Avenue was like a feat and when it
happened we were like let's just keep
the glory of it because it's all
everyone wants to believe is that you
can move around that City easily
um but it was it's a funny thing you
mention it because
it it was definitely a stop and go
situation you know you get very limited
we wanted to shoot New York because it's
you know the book is set in New York
City
um and we didn't really want to double
those streets but it's that is not an
easy thing to do
no it's that's my only objection to the
film everything else great just the lack
of traffic is where I draw the line
um I'm trying to sell an idealized New
Yorker yeah
by the way it totally works with the
idealized New York I'm totally teasing
you guys so I've been I've been a huge
fan of scoot for a long time
um and uh he doesn't really get to do
roles like this you know was was that
one of the reasons why you wanted to put
him in the movie no I mean it's funny
we've known scoot for you know uh well
over a decade or more he was a he was
kind of a a commercial ringer
um right what we mean by that is so we
started in commercials before we did you
know our features and there were always
these commercials that you needed to get
an actor who could just make it work and
there were like five or six of them that
were always they would come in and they
would just crush it and believe it or
not scoot was one of those guys it was
in the comedy space yeah it was very
very funny so we knew him before he
became this big dramatic actor it was a
very funny actor so when we told the
studio they were like really scoot I
mean he's like such a respected drama
actor we're like no he's very funny and
then and it was it was a joy to watch
him get to do that and also you know he
was really excited because as a first he
got to show his kids something he
actually did because most of his stuff
is you know on the margin so talk a
little bit about maybe some of the the
bigger debates you in the studio had
what were they over and how did you end
up solving those you know debates you
know strangely this is going to sound
like you know we're we're we're we're
not sharing the you know how the sausage
made or whatever but it's you know
strangely
um the studio was very in sync about all
the major things in the movie and some
of that you know comes down to just luck
like everybody agreed Javier Madam would
be the perfect person for them all so
when you get Javier burdem everybody's
like oh great everybody agreed Patrick
and Paul are the perfect composers for
it so you go great it's when you kind of
don't get those first choices that the
riffs kind of you know what I mean so
the fault lines kind of show I think for
us the thing we were most afraid of was
that they were going to make us make the
character talk because that was going to
take it tonally in a different direction
where he would be a wisecracking kind of
crocodile as well said you know driven
by a comedic actor and and they kind of
got that that was important to the tone
of the of the movie and that he only
expresses himself through song so we
sort of were able to largely avoid I
think all of the big contentious things
for for us you know what I mean
um what'd you say yeah I think so I mean
there was one
um there was a question about while we
were shooting can you please use
Crocodile Rock and it was like that
thing that you know it's like when
something very clear is presented you
sometimes resist it and we were like
well no that's just two on the nose it's
too obvious and it kept coming up from
other people oddly you know like the
actors were like oh you know the old
John song Crocodile Rock we're like yeah
they're like you should use that and we
were like all right if you hear that
enough you should probably listen
um so we had a little snippet at the end
of the movie where
um Sean sings it and of course the
audience like loved it and we looked at
each other and we were like yeah we'll
climb credit yeah exactly well
um that's one of the things listen I
love talking about the editing process
because that's where it all comes
together so um talk a little bit about
what you learned from like that first
test screening or early friends and
family screenings that actually impacted
the finished film
I think you know we learned a lot about
the pace and energy that comes when you
have a musical you know it's a very
strong flavor and an audience once you
give them a taste of that they want more
and you know we we kept sort of reducing
our space between the musical numbers in
order to do that
um but the film you know it's pretty
close to what we shot we only I think
caught two scenes out of the movie but
it was in the areas where we felt like
okay it's time to get this crocodile
singing again because it's been a minute
um and you know we didn't have we only
had two test screenings they both did
very well
um but the thing that's crazy is I mean
you know that we've done mostly R-rated
comedies right so what you're normally
getting is very sort of cynical you know
people in their 20s standing in line you
know waiting to rip you apart or in the
best case scenario just go hysterical at
any of the vignettes you do and the
thing that was hilarious is you get
there and there's just like throngs of
kids you know what I mean we're like oh
man we're like this is a whole new thing
like people yeah like what what is the
mind of a six-year-old with a popcorn
the size of their head going to say
about what our choices are on color
palette do you know what I mean like
it's it was a strange thing to truth
it's like a truth bomb yeah it's a test
to test a movie at 11 o'clock in the
morning you know with like a row of
juice boxes was just a brand new
experience for us and it was bizarre you
know it was like very strange it's like
it's the moment you realize oh this was
this was the this was the audience that
we're making yeah exactly and you and
you learn I mean a kid audience is I
mean there's no hiding they're not being
polite they're not quiet and like you
know what normally happens in test
Alliance where everyone collaps and
laughs and then you know rip you apart
on cards these kids let you know in the
moment if they're there or not I
actually was happy that my theater was
filled with kids yesterday because you
can you can feel if they're enjoying it
because uh or not because they'll start
talking or they want to go to the
bathroom or you you know what I mean
like you know yeah you know or your
worst fear they like cry and walk out
yeah
um I'm just thinking I can't imagine
what it's like for you guys uh sitting
for directors watching that test
screening for the first time just
knowing that you're you know it's all
come down to it's funny it's really
really hard but it's also like over the
years it's completely invaluable it's
it's a weird part of the process that
especially if you're making comedies or
especially if we're just plugging in our
yeah especially if you're making
comedies or especially if you're making
you know something that requires the
constant sort of input of the audience
you know musicals being the same thing
you know
um you kind of really need to feel it in
front of a big audience because you're
otherwise you're you're going off your
own internal Rhythm which which can fail
you after you've seen it 40 or 50 times
yeah I've spoken to a lot of directors
who talk about how you know when you've
been in the editing room for six months
with something you no longer find it
funny and you want to take it out of the
movie and you need to be reminded no the
sequence worked for a reason don't [ __ ]
with it yeah you really start to
cannibalize your own your your own you
know babies after after a couple months
I mean I'm sure you know from speaking
to directors but having been through so
many test screenings over the years
especially with comedies you know we
have such thick skins you know I mean
like we by now you know when we were
doing while I mean again this the new
the new twists were kids
um but you know we've had some tough
test screens in the past you know what I
mean like meaning in terms of your
anxiety and your build up and what's
going to be funny and what's not and you
know so but you always come out you
always come out um with a clearer sense
of the movement 100
uh what do you think would surprise soon
to be fans of the film about the actual
making of the movie if anything well I
think
um how little
um we cheated uh with Javier bergdem
meaning he rehearsed for almost five
months and uh demanded when he showed up
on set to do the numbers from start to
finish because he was so like proud that
he had like worked as hard as he had and
he really did not want us to ever bring
on a double or to have any other part of
his work not be him so I think you would
look at it and go that you know that's
how I've ever done there's no way he did
all of that he really did all of it it
was incredible well this goes back to
what I was saying when Javier commits to
a role he commits to a role which is why
I think the studio was like you're never
getting him yeah yeah I mean we were
incredibly lucky and he works incredibly
hard and as as Josh said just I mean
there was no we had dance doubles and
voice doubles and we were ready to
auto-tune him and we used none of those
things or people you know they just sat
on the sidelines waiting yeah I need
someone to auto-tune me on a daily basis
I appreciate if you could hook me up I
think the other kind of amazing thing
with with Javier was was you know he is
such an actor first before a um sort of
whatever you know celebrity whatever he
is that he um doesn't leave set so
literally he would not go back to his
trailer he would sit in a chair and read
through his script and to the point
where sometimes the crew would be like
it's freaking me out like can he I can't
set my shot and he would often jump up
and be like I'll Stand in so he would
literally like there to kind of he did
almost everything but like carry the
equipment it was incredible
yeah that that's uh I love hearing
stories like that uh just like people
that are that professional and want to
be there I've you know there's a few
other actors I've spoken to or and that
like being on set in between they don't
want to go back to their trailer I know
it's it's a weird one because
it's kind of it's amazing but it can be
uncomfortable like in a weird way
I'm so used to just being free to do our
work well there's often that thing that
happens which is like you know they
command a lot of energy and eyes and you
know and what happens is when an actor
like that's on set everybody's sort of
in on their you know everybody's tense
and on their best behavior no matter how
relaxed the actor is and then if the
actor usually the actor leaves and
everyone kind of takes a breath and then
you know starts to you know go check
their cell phones or you know have their
small talk or you know eats with their
mouth open from Craft service or
whatever it is and sometimes like when
an actor stands on set it's just that
thing that it keeps everything what's
interesting was after people got over
that and got used to it was he was
around listening to problems and I think
he does it so that he can help people
solve their problem so he'd be like I
could walk over to This Light if you
need me yeah to be you know it wasn't
there was no sort of membrane between
what he did yeah but he could do and
what we was one of the best ones yeah so
be sure to run out of time with you guys
have some other questions
um you mentioned distant already which
is coming out next year which is a
completely different film for the two of
you um what can you tease people about
it
you know it's a it was it was a very
contained story um that's what we were
excited about it's really just one man
against the elements um and then
there's a Twist where he finds another
Survivor and you know that's and it's
Anthony Ramos and Naomi Scott and
they're both fantastic and I think
what's fun about it is it really sort of
takes Anthony in a different direction
because it's very you know it has a very
dramatic core because of the set of
circumstance but there's some humor you
know so it gives a range for this actor
that you haven't seen and he really is
fantastic and it's really a sort of it's
we joke it's a survival horror romantic
comedy
oh my life
uh when do you think because I believe
and I could be wrong it comes out early
next year yeah it's supposed to be
January end of January end of January so
when do you think uh the marketing will
start where we'll see a poster and a
trailer and everything else we're
already starting to look at um posters
and trailers so I think it's going to
start gearing up soon yeah
uh how much are you debating or how much
are you working with the studio in terms
of
um how much you want to show in the
marketing versus you know keeping those
surprises Under Wraps because the thing
that people don't realize
um is that like most people not like the
average person goes to the movies like
two times a year so a lot of the
marketing is always geared towards those
rare people that go don't go that often
but you know for people that do go all
the time and watch a trailer they don't
want everything ruined it's like
delicate balance it's a very it's a very
astute point and it's something we
always struggle with no matter how great
the marketing department you know is at
whatever Studio we're at which is we
always believe that less is more like
you said um because we're crazy moving
goers and you know that's the kind of
stuff we like
um what's interesting that we've been
told and we resisted it often especially
with comedies is
that there's a recognition Factor that's
just true and factual where a lot of
people see something and if they like it
they like to see it again in the movie
and be reminded of it from the materials
like oddly jokes that appear in in
trailers play better in the test
screenings you do immediately afterwards
because the audience we always were like
you're ruining it you're giving it why
are you giving this joke away and then
you'll see like wow well you can tell
they recognize that joke so it's a weird
it's always a weird balance it's like
you wanna as cinephiles ourselves you
want to have that Perfect trailer that
just teases without you know giving away
the whole beginning middle and end of
the of the thing but we love we love to
tease out stuff like on and we rarely
get to do it as you said correctly you
know on office Christmas party we did a
teaser trailer that was just a voiceover
that we wrote for Jason Bateman to do
over some images
um and that was it and um you know it
did very well still one of our favorites
but you rarely get that opportunity
usually you know it's expensive to
Market a movie I'm sure you know that
and it's more expensive now than it ever
has been and so there's always this urge
to try to
sell everything you've got in that and
give as much information as you as you
can have and I think you know there are
a few
anticipatory sort of well-known IP that
you can play with you know whether it be
Spider-Man or Ghostbusters where you can
have just a moment you know a logo a
familiar character that an audience will
lean into because they are so excited
about tease you know normally a lot of
those characters that you're sitting in
front of behind you do you know what I
mean can do that
um but when you're you know when you're
doing something that people don't know
that much about you know they they need
to unfortunately be told a lot more so
it's it's a tricky art and it's a hard
one to get right I read that you guys
might be doing Oregon Trail
um is that like true what's the deal
with this well it's you know this this
was born of wanting to work with Patrick
and Paul again who did the music for
this and they've both been very obsessed
with Oregon Trail and you know we were
talking about what we could cook up next
because we really want to do another
Musical and they mentioned that and um
we now have the rights to it and we're
putting it together alongside them and
and some other extensions for us that's
sort of returning a little bit to Our
Roots in comedy marrying it with the fun
of doing a big Musical and also just the
ambition of kind of taking that very
seriously as well and making a big
historical Western Westward Expansion
epic that's also about dying from
dysentery I mean for people that don't
realize this is a iconic video game that
I mean like ever well let's just say
it's an early one of the earliest video
games yeah it was the only video game
you were quote allowed to play in school
because it was educational so everybody
would like spend their free period And
whatever size science computer lab like
basically playing this early video game
but actually it's right up there with
like snake and Tetris in terms of really
complicated IP I mean it's not you know
it's it's an early very early sort of
Lo-Fi role-playing kind of type game and
it's but it's it always had this dark
band of humor running through it because
your chances of dying from everything
from dysentery to a cut to anything was
was like basically every move you ended
up dying so that was just death it does
seem like it could be ripe for comedy in
terms of you have this huge group going
west and then you know literally every
five minutes someone gets a cut and
they're just dead right exactly right or
it was the period where you had to have
nine kids because you know only two of
them would survive so can I ask where
are you in the development process of
the of the project yeah we're putting it
together right now um with a writer and
then um looking to partner with a studio
a studio studio yeah oh so you guys like
literally have the rights and are
putting it together yes with the
partners of the original Publishers yeah
we're bringing it to people and we want
to find that we want to find a home for
where we know it'll get made in the
right way so we're kind of that was a
little bit what we did on this project
which was really got the rights
developed and then found our studio
partner we're finding that to be a
really kind of effective creative
approach yeah that that's uh I can see
how that would be because you also that
way it doesn't get stuck in development
hell it's like okay we have all this
here's the budget we need this is what
we want to do do you want to finance it
yeah and I think they know what they're
buying too so it's good for them because
they're they're not
um they're not uh being duped they kind
of know okay this is the movie we're
gonna make so do you envision this as
like a like a PG-13 like fun kind of
movie or because you can play it two
different ways I think you know there's
a there's there's been a discussion
about our rated
um I think we it's interesting I think
we want to find its tone to be funny and
not sort of pull any punches you know
and be able to be Darkly funny but we
also want it to be you know accessible
enough for for a big audience so I think
we're just trying to answer that
question now yeah also I think it's
great that um uh that you know Justin
and Ben are gonna do the music which is
you know obviously you must have had a
great time working together on Lyle we
did I mean they're incredible I mean
there's nothing shy of of that I mean
they they they are are creating
something
um you know that has been lost for for a
long time which is you know a regular I
mean there's a few people of which there
they are you know right up there you
know creating popular music for movies
you know I mean um and not just writing
for Broadway and not being adapted but
they actually are creating new musical
you know towering works of of uh musical
theater for the film so that's that's
just incredible to watch yeah my last
thing on this um I can't imagine it's
easy to get the rights to something that
was created in the 70s how does that
actually work
are you talking about for Oregon Trail
you're talking about for Lyle properties
oh no for for Oregon Trail because
that's like you know a few people anyway
what is that like well it's owned by a
publishing company and um you know we
had to do what we often have to do and
what we had to do for Lyle which is to
give them a sense of on multiple phone
calls and zooms you know of what we what
our intentions are and how exploitive we
want to be and how truthful we want to
be to the original material and what
it's going to look and feel like and you
know all people are very protective of
of their IP as they should be and um you
know these guys have so far been great
Partners in allowing us to take it and
run with it
um you know and also we've made them
producing Partners basically so the the
Publishers are are now our partners
we'll be involved with the make sure
that it's done right yeah yeah that um
uh that I can that the smart move oh
that makes sense um listen I I could uh
I I I'm just going to say
um congrats on everything and thank you
for your time